Digamos que nos interesa conocer la cantidad
aproximada de habitantes en nuestra ciudad. La
única información que tenemos es que hay 388,905
mujeres y 314,906 hombres. Lo más sencillo aquí
es hacer una suma o adición, ¿verdad? Pero como
los números son muy grandes, y no requerimos un
número exacto, queremos solamente una cantidad
aproximada, podemos hacer una estimación en
esta suma. Recordemos que una estimación
es una aproximación a la solución exacta;
para llegar a ella es recomendable redondear
los números antes de hacer el cálculo. Entonces,
para obtener la estimación que requerimos en
nuestro ejemplo, el primer paso será redondear
los números que tenemos para que sea más sencillo
sumarlos. En este caso redondearemos a la decena
de millar más cercana, esto quiere decir que
buscaremos un nuevo número cercano al original
en el que haya ceros a partir de las unidades de
millar. Empecemos con 388,905. ¿Qué número ocupa
el valor posicional de las decenas de millar?
Veamos. Tenemos unidades, decenas, centenas,
unidades de millar y decenas de millar; esto
significa que tenemos 38 decenas de millar más
8,905. Siguiendo las reglas de redondeo, si las
unidades de millar son mayores o iguales a cinco
el redondeo será hacia arriba. En este caso, en
el valor posicional de las unidades de millar,
tenemos un 8, entonces, si tenemos que redondear
hacia arriba ¿qué decena de millar se acerca más
a 388,905? Claro, 390,000; ése es el redondeo de
la cantidad de mujeres de nuestra ciudad. Observa
que a partir de las unidades de millar sólo
tenemos ceros. Ahora continuemos con 314,906;
hagamos lo mismo: identifiquemos
primero las decenas de millar, unidades,
decenas, centenas, unidades de millar
y decenas de millar. En este caso,
tenemos 31 decenas de millar más 4,906. Ahora, en
la posición de unidades de millar, tenemos un 4,
por lo que debemos redondear hacia abajo. ¿Cuál
es, entonces, el número más cercano a 314,906,
donde haya ceros a partir de las unidades de
millar? Pausa el video e intenta resolverlo.
Si dijiste 310,000 estás en lo correcto. Igual
que antes, a partir de las unidades de millar,
sólo tenemos ceros. Ahora ya podemos sumar las
cantidades para llegar a un estimado del total
de la población de la ciudad: 390,000 + 310,000 =
cero, cero, cero, cero, 9 + 1 = 10, 3 + 3 y 1 = 7,
700,000, hay 700,000 habitantes aproximadamente en
la ciudad. Otra forma de considerar una estimación
es dentro de un intervalo. Veamos un ejemplo.
Los estadios de fútbol con mayor capacidad de
Perú son el Estadio Monumental, en Lima, con
una capacidad máxima de 85,000 espectadores,
y el Estadio Monumental de la UNSA, en Arequipa,
con capacidad de 40,000. La suma de la asistencia
máxima de ambos estadios es igual a 125,000
espectadores, pero si los partidos son a puerta
cerrada tendremos la asistencia mínima: 0. Durante
un campeonato reciente, en un partido importante,
asistieron al estadio de Lima 58,306 espectadores,
y en otro emocionante encuentro la asistencia en
el estadio de Arequipa alcanzó 33,583 personas.
Si redondeamos ambas cantidades a la decena de
millar más cercana, obtenemos que, en Lima, el
estimado de asistentes ese día fue de 60,000,
y en Arequipa, fue de 30,000. El resultado
que obtenemos de la suma de ambas cantidades
es 90,000; entonces el estimado del total de
asistentes en ambos partidos es 90,000. Habíamos
visto que 125,000 espectadores era la asistencia
máxima total entre los dos estadios, así que la
capacidad total que sumaron estos estadios durante
sus mejores partidos fue menor, y definitivamente
fue mayor a la asistencia mínima. Por ahora lo
dejaremos aquí. Nos vemos en el siguiente video.